tell me how the dion sanders deal
happened
so by the way epic epic get dion
is a thousand percent better than i ever
thought he would be he fits perfectly
like you can literally say
whatever the [ __ ] you want to him he
gets it he knows his busting balls he
doesn't take offense
um so we were you worried that he might
yes
yeah like hall of famer he made a lot of
the athletes famous athletes or even
personalities we've dealt with
do not fit in they come from first of
all network people
and people who have money don't have the
work ethic we do we're born from the
internet the only way people find out
who you are
is because you're better funnier worked
harder than other people that's it
that's the culture here um if you have a
lot of money
you're an athlete you've been told
you're the best your whole life you may
have a very different like work ethic
than we do
um so we we have a podcast out of philly
uh million dollars worth of game amazing
most underrated podcasts there is
they're hilarious hilarious
so they're friends with dion um and of
course they are
and they're like hey he's looking and he
they did the introduction
and we went to uh to barstool yeah to
erica and i
we flew down met with him it's like what
do you want um
it seemed like a good fit there was a
lot going on
it's one of those things combo he's
expensive we were willing to pay
it was a good look for us we had the pen
deal going on so it's like football show
but he's awesome he's better than in in
everything's like
credibility as well like okay we can
compete with these big guys
but he's been i don't know how he's
going to continue it with the job
but he is for those that don't know he
just what jackson is
did you see this press conference uh i
saw a clip of i didn't see it it's
insane
it looked like someone said it looked
like coming to america it did
he had like this calvin rate of like
cars coming to the gym
like people dropping it was very prime
time but
he's not super prime time off camera
yeah
like he is but he isn't like he's a guy
like that
obviously you know if i'm with someone
younger
and like dion sanders they made like
who's that mike really it's like to me
he's like
he was it two three most famous
guys like bo jackson dion sanders like
they're it
um you ever heard of anybody playing in
a football game in a baseball game in
the same day
[Music]
so i didn't know what to expect because
the persona but he's so down-to-earth
and
you really like you what did i say oh a
guy from boston dan shaughnessy
called him a fraud the other day and i'm
a bossing guy i'm like hey dion he's
like
and you can bust a ball but like you
should dump a a thing a gator on his
head like mccarthy's like i [ __ ] hate
that guy
like he he's he's very real very
authentic i didn't know what to expect
but he's uh he's as good an athlete to
interact with i probably have a handful
where um
who else is up there greg olsen yeah i
couldn't be it like he's one of the
early guys
but i'm as comfortable talking to you
wasn't he doing the uh
the van talk right he left super bowl
media day media day because they won't
let us in
to come talk to us in the van early and
by the way
there is nothing like i'm a huge loyalty
guy
like i really really appreciate the guys
who were with us before we blew up in
in or before they blew up and stay with
us um
goes a long way and i'm the same way but
it is crazy like i went to a party the
other day
in the hampton is no big deal but it was
like i walk in and blake griffin was
there
he literally like grabs me and like just
he's like i love barcelona
just grab me we went up and shot the
[ __ ] in a room for like an hour it's
surreal [ __ ] like that
yeah that that is it was still stunning
the point when i realized like
this is no longer bar stool of i think
that everyone grew up in college
right was uh the joe burrow or coach o
whatever interview
i was like wait what that was the first
interview that they gave yeah how the
[ __ ] did this yeah it's great you know
we've always been with the athletes
very strange because athletes
unlike espn where they're out and asking
athletes like ask to come the ones that
do well like kevin hayes
who's had an unbelievable season for the
flyers
like i'm legitimately very good friends
with these through the system
and it we got to the point kind of what
you said a lot of the guys who play
sports now or in the pros
they grew up with us like they were
reading it in like high school
so the the they're like fans and then
they know we're not out to get them like
we're never trying to get
people like gotcha quotes we're trying
to be funny and interesting give a
different look and they appreciate it
but i think that's also
why you guys are so successful right
it's like media is shifting now to
nobody cares about
what does x you know network how do they
take what i said
manipulate it take a quote and put their
spin on it
like i just wanna hear what you say i
just wanna hear what greg golson says
whatever and you guys
just created platforms where they can do
that and we're protective like i mean
kevin hayes like for example we got a
video sent to us he didn't do anything
wrong he was just making a ruckus in
like a chinese food restaurant
it was very funny i was like dude like
clean it up like we're not gonna post it
just heads up so
you know we're not it we're not out
we're not teams guys
yeah we're not out trying to make people
look bad and we're also
one of the few places especially
nowadays where like
we don't really apologize for hey you
like to drink beer and like go [ __ ]
chicks like that's like frowned upon
somehow now
like we don't it's like all right we're
guys like
we're not we're not bad we're not what
everyone's just authentic
correct it's just like literally this is
what i would do if the camera wasn't
here so like if you want to watch watch
if not then
that's always always the [ __ ] that i've
heard the negative about me they're
always like
if he says this on camera imagine what
he says off camera it's like that
that's the [ __ ] point like you're
getting as
unfiltered that's why you're mad to
begin with is because i literally said
the worst thing i was going to say
right right and that's it like there's
nothing else i'm talking as if we're not
on camera that's how i am
all the time i've always said i like the
people i don't like
there's people who've come through the
walls and it's like oh i like this
person i don't like this person this
person is cool
put a camera on me yeah 24 7
you're gonna get the same exact person
24 7. there's
a lot of people probably not like that